the little voice in your head is called
the insecurity devil the insecurity
devil on your shoulder is saying to you
don't do this because when you fail the
girl you like your brother your mom your
teacher like someone's gonna think you
suck and you believe them and that's the
problem when I started public speaking
and losing out on speaking gigs left and
right because I cursed I knew that I was
going to double down on what got me
there which was I'm not going to
overvalue other people's opinions I'm
going to value my opinion about myself
if people really got into a place of
just doing things that they want to do
and not worrying about what people
thought about it everybody would take
risks in their 20s the reason people are
scared of the world is they actually
think getting fired or having their
startup fail or them not being able to
be an influencer because nobody gave a
[__] is a bad thing when I think it's a
great thing this all comes down to
confidence and insecurity the reason you
won't do something is you are too
insecure to do